hey guys Eric here joined with Michael
Michael actually just got back from
Blizzard he checked out starcraft
remastered yep sure did I got to play a
little bit of it and I got to see it in
all of its glory and we're gonna kind of
talk you through what's new what's not
new and we'll show you some gameplay
footage as well so one of the biggest
things or biggest changes I guess is
that there's 1080p now 4k resolution 16
p9 native aspect ratio you know how did
that look compared to you know obviously
the old-school look you know when I when
I first started playing the remastered
version I kind of looked at it and said
this looks very similar to what I've
already been playing for all these years
you know can't really appreciate how
much work they put into you know redoing
all the art and up raising all the
graphics and the high resolution
textures until you look directly at the
old game which you can do by they have
implemented you can hit f5 and it
automatically in real time reverts back
to the old graphics so in that moment
when I did hit at 5 and I looked at the
game again I was like whoa this is
actually a very big deal they put in a
lot of work in making sure they retain
that same spirit of StarCraft while
making it look at least somewhat modern
in terms of the gameplay have they done
anything to change it or is it still the
same game nope from the from the get-go
they said this is gonna be the exact
same Starcraft game that you've been
playing ever since you know the latest
patch which was I think what 1.18 with
that said people who have Starcraft
remastered can play with everyone else
who's playing the old game because there
is absolutely no changes that the
gameplay the gameplay has been refined
over and over again for so many years
that at this point you know there would
make no sense to kind of modernize the
gameplay are there any other like
features that's being added with
remastered any type of matchmaking or
something like that yeah so everyone who
has remastered is going to be able to do
matchmaking
with other people who have Starcraft
remastered so you know the old-school
Starcraft players aren't going to get
the matchmaking system so in terms of
matchmaking it's gonna be a little bit
limited in the pool I imagine because
you're not implementing all the players
who are still playing
the old-school games also there's gonna
be a player ladder so you can see how
you rank among everybody else and it's
also gonna be launching from the
Blizzard app which makes things a lot
easier it's part of the Blizzard
ecosystem now so everyone on your
friends list who's playing overwatch or
here's a storm or whatever on the
Blizzard app it's gonna be able to
launch from there and you'll see it all
there playing starcraft remastered i can
jump into a game and it's supposed to
work seamlessly with Windows 10 so it's
modernized in that sense as well are
there any changes in terms of like the
single-player or anything like that yeah
yeah they're essentially the
single-player campaign is the same but
they do have higher res cutscenes for
you cool yeah and then this isn't
directly for single-player but there is
a upgraded audio so I think they've
recorded almost everything in the game
so it'll you'll have higher quality
audio that's also in a 44 kilohertz
audio frequency so it sounds a lot
better too but it's all the same same
music the same voice lines that you
recognize from back in the day it just
sounds a lot better I guess one of my
final questions is it's interesting to
see that they remastered broodwar and
Starcraft obviously especially now when
I feel like RTS is aren't as popular as
they used to be because I like MOBAs and
things like that who do you think this
remaster is kind of targeted for its
fanservice taste they've said straight
up - I asked them and they're like you
know we're doing this for the fans for
the people who are still there like
playing Starcraft but you know want
something that maybe looks a little bit
better runs a little bit a little bit
better on modern systems but that's also
not to say that if you're if you're not
trying to get back into it or if you
dropped off after like a couple years
ago you can still jump in and try and
learn this game awesome so when does
Starcraft remaster come out and for how
much August 14th and it's gonna be 15
bucks you can't get the original one for
free but if you do want the remaster
you're gonna have to shell out 15 bucks
all right cool well I'm gonna hold out
hope that now that they've done
Starcraft remastered maybe they'll give
me my favorite Diablo 2 9 oh you're
looking for that but who knows but thank
you so much Michael again we appreciate
all of you guys for watching this video
on starcraft remastered and we hope you
like it
if you want to see more Blizzard related
videos and whatnot hit subscribe for us
in YouTube and we'll
you guys next time thanks so much
[Music]
you